.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
In diesem Film begebe ich mich
auf die komplizierteste Reise
meines Lebens.
Wenn wir von da aus gehen, haben wir
dann ein Problem mit Ihnen?
Ist es verboten?
- Es ist verboten.
Wenn Sie von Armenien aus gehen,
haben Sie ein Problem mit uns.
Mein Name ist Christof Franzen.
Zehn Jahre berichtete ich
als Korrespondent aus Moskau.
Auf dieser Reise stosse ich ständig
an undurchdringliche Grenzen -
und das auf der Schnittstelle
zwischen Asien und Europa.
Warum fahren wir nicht da durch?
Sind da die Friedenstruppen?
- Ja.
Weil es da
russische Friedenstruppen hat.
* Christof Franzen
spricht russisch. *
Wie geht's da drüben?
Flughafen Baku.
Ich warte auf meinen Kameramann
Evgeny, der aus Moskau anreist.
Da ist er.
Während meiner Korrespondentenzeit
in Russland
waren wir ein dickes Gespann.
* Sie sprechen russisch. *
Und auch auf dieser Reise
kann es nicht schaden,
einen russischen Kameramann
an meiner Seite zu haben.
Da, wo wir unterwegs sein werden,
spielt Russland
überall eine zentrale Rolle.
Als die Sowjetunion zusammenbrach,
entstanden im Süden des Kaukasus
aus den ehemaligen Sowjetrepubliken
drei unabhängige Staaten:
Aserbaidschan, Armenien und Georgien.
30 Jahre und ein paar Kriege später
sind drei Gebilde dazugekommen:
Bergkarabach,
Südossetien und Abchasien.
Und überall ungelöste Konflikte,
undurchdringliche Grenzen,
Stacheldraht und Soldaten.
Meine Reise durch dieses politisch
brisante Gebiet beginnt in Baku
am Kaspischen Meer und führt mich
über Schuscha in Bergkarabach
nach Armenien, Georgien,
an die Konfliktzonen Südossetien
und Abchasien bis ans Schwarze Meer.
* Sanfte Musik *
Baku ist die Hauptstadt
von Aserbaidschan.
An allerbester Strandlage
inmitten von Hochglanz-Architektur
hat hier vor eineinhalb Jahren
der sog. Trophäen-Park eröffnet,
der Park der erbeuteten Kriegswaffen.
führten Aserbaidschan und Armenien
zum zweiten Mal Krieg gegeneinander
um die Region von Bergkarabach.
Die Aserbaidschaner
eroberten dabei Territorien zurück,
die sie vor 30 Jahren
verloren hatten.
Aserbaidschan gehört der Sieg
und das sollen alle sehen.
"Karabach gehört zu Aserbaidschan"
steht auf der Wand,
die mit erbeuteten armenischen
Autokennzeichen gepflastert ist.
Ein beliebtes Fotomotiv.
Der Park ist v.a. für ein
einheimisches Publikum gedacht.
Auf Anfrage dürfen wir drehen -
aber nur mit dem Handy,
so die Auflage.
Geht es darum, die eigene Stärke
und Überlegenheit zu demonstrieren
oder den Gegner zu demütigen?
Oder soll auch die nächste Generation
schon darauf vorbereitet werden,
wer der Todfeind ist?
Mich lässt dieser Park
etwas ratlos zurück.
* Muezzin-Gesang *
Aserbaidschan ist muslimisch
und kulturell und sprachlich
mit der Türkei verwandt.
Das Land wird autokratisch regiert.
Auf der Liste der Pressefreiheit
nimmt es den Platz 154 von 180 ein.
An unserer Seite haben wir
einen offiziellen Begleiter.
Mir geht es auf dieser Reise
nicht darum, herauszufinden,
welche Länder mehr oder weniger
Kriegsschuld tragen.
Ich möchte wissen, was die Menschen
in dieser Gegend hier denken,
die traditionell
stark von Russland geprägt ist -
gerade in der heutigen Zeit,
wo die Karten zwischen West und Ost
wieder neu gemischt werden.
Und schon morgen
möchte ich bei etwas dabei sein,
bei dem ich bis zum Schluss
nicht sicher sein kann, ob es klappt.
6 Uhr morgens, Busbahnhof Baku.
Wir wollen eine Reisegruppe
in zurückerobertes Gebiet begleiten.
Doch es passiert etwas, an das wir
uns in diesem Land gewöhnen müssen:
Offenbar
fehlt noch von irgendjemandem
in irgendeinem Ministerium
die Bewilligung.
Unser offizieller Begleiter
tut sein Möglichstes.
Auf einmal kommt ein Telefonanruf
und wir dürfen tatsächlich
einsteigen.
Wir begleiten ehemalige Bewohner
der Stadt Schuscha,
die nach 30 Jahren
ihre alte Heimat besichtigen dürfen.
Fahren Sie nach Schuscha? Heim?
- Ja.
Wie lange dauert das?
Die ganze Strecke? 5 bis 6 Std.
Der Fahrer ist anscheinend
immer noch nicht begeistert,
dass ein Kamerateam an Bord ist.
Doch schliesslich
verlassen wir die Stadt
unter den Augen
des allgegenwärtigen Heidar Alijew,
dem Vater und Vorgänger
des jetzigen Präsidenten.
Es ist im Mai 2022,
als wir unterwegs sind.
Die Bohrtürme erinnern mich daran,
dass im Moment westliche Politiker
in Baku nach Alternativen
zu russischen Rohstoffen fahnden.
Die Menschen hier im Bus
haben sich Wochen zuvor
auf eine Warteliste setzen lassen,
um die ersehnte Reise zu machen.
Schuscha ist
die Kulturhauptstadt unseres Landes.
Nicht nur jetzt, es war immer schon
unser kulturelles Zentrum -
während der Sowjetzeit,
aber auch schon vorher.
Ich war 13 Jahre alt,
als wir die Stadt verloren.
Seitdem warte ich jeden Tag darauf,
sie zu sehen.
Das ist ein bewegender Moment.
Ich war in vielen Ländern,
aber so aufgeregt wie jetzt -
das lässt sich mit
keinen anderen Gefühlen vergleichen.
Wir sind auf dem Weg nach Schuscha.
Nebst Stepanakert
ist das die zweitgrösste Stadt
des umstrittenen Gebiets
Bergkarabach.
Der Status von Bergkarabach
ist kompliziert.
Es liegt zwischen Armenien,
das von Russland unterstützt wird,
und Aserbaidschan,
das die Türken zum Freund hat.
1991 erklärte es sich für unabhängig.
In Bergkarabach lebten früher sowohl
Armenier als auch Aserbaidschaner.
Zwischen 1992 und 1994
tobte ein Krieg.
Die Armenier konnten diesen Krieg mit
russischer Unterstützung gewinnen.
Die Aserbaidschaner
mussten aus Bergkarabach fliehen.
Im Herbst 2020 eroberte Aserbaidschan
Teile des Kernlandes von Bergkarabach
mit Schuscha und umliegende Gebiete
zurück, die Armenien besetzt hielt.
Als unser Bus in ehemals
von Armenien besetztes Gebiet kommt,
eskortiert uns die Polizei.
Das hat den Vorteil,
dass die Reisenden nicht jedes Mal
an einem der zahlreichen Checkpoints
kontrolliert werden.
Die Stimmung im Bus
wird spürbar gedrückt,
als wir
durch die zerstörten Gebiete fahren.
Es ist ein Landstrich,
geprägt von unendlich viel
Brutalität, Leid und Trauer.
Gebe Gott der Welt Frieden.
Jetzt läuft in der Ukraine
auch ein Krieg, wir verstehen sie.
Nur derjenige kann das verstehen,
der solches Leid erlebt hat.
Und die, die am Rand stehen, sagen:
"Ja, wir verstehen,
dort ist ein Krieg."
Aber das sind einfach nur Worte.
Nur die, die das selbst erlebt
haben, wissen, was das heisst.
Dem ersten Krieg
zwischen 1992 und 1994
fielen Zehntausende Menschen
zum Opfer.
Armenier - wie hier im Bild -,
aber genauso Aserbaidschaner.
Hunderttausende auf beiden Seiten
wurden vertrieben.
Gegenseitig
bezichtigen sich die Gegner,
Zivilisten zu attackieren
und Massaker zu verüben.
Die Ethnien
leben fortan praktisch getrennt.
30 Jahre nach dem ersten Krieg.
(Mann über Lautsprecher)
Ilham Alijew.
Tayyip Erdogan.
Im zweiten Krieg war Aserbaidschan
mithilfe modernster Waffen
klar überlegen.
Die Kampfdrohnen
wurden u.a. aus der Türkei geliefert.
Schätzungen zufolge starben innerhalb
von nur 44 Tagen 5'000 Menschen.
Der Krieg von 2020 veränderte
die Machtverhältnisse im Südkaukasus.
Nur Russland scheint über all
die Jahre fest im Sattel zu sitzen.
Die Russen spielten in diesem Krieg
ein undurchsichtiges Spiel.
Eigentlich Schutzmacht Armeniens,
lieferten sie Waffen an beide Seiten.
Der Kreml vermittelte dann
einen Waffenstillstand
und schickte
eine 2'000-köpfige Friedenstruppe,
die seither
den fragilen Status quo sichert.
Schon bald kommen wir
ans Ziel unserer Reise:
oben auf dem Berg,
das ersehnte Schuscha.
Meine Kindheit, meine Jugend -
alles ist hier gelaufen.
Diese Orte sind mir sehr vertraut.
Es ist jetzt sehr schwierig
für mich, aber ich freue mich auch.
Sehen Sie,
was unsere Leute jetzt machen:
Sie machen alles neu.
Die anderen haben nur geklaut.
Plünderer.
Auch mir fällt auf:
überall grosse Baustellen.
Offensichtlich
haben die Aserbaidschaner viel vor
mit ihrem zurückeroberten Gebiet.
Vorbei an einem weiteren Checkpoint
erreichen wir Schuscha.
Es herrscht viel Betrieb
in der Stadt,
aber ich sehe nur Baustellen,
Arbeiter und Soldaten.
Der 8. November: Tag des Sieges.
Seid ihr Russen
oder Aserbaidschaner?
Aserbaidschaner.
Die Ankunft ist hektisch.
Die Leute haben nur 2 Std. Zeit
und zerstreuen sich sofort
in alle Richtungen.
Wen sollen wir begleiten?
Wir entscheiden uns
für eine Grossfamilie.
Ich bin gespannt,
was sie sich anschauen werden.
Lasst uns gehen.
Da lang geht's zum schönsten Platz.
Dort, wo alle sassen.
Hast du das Konzert nicht gesehen?
Wie alt waren Sie,
als Sie die Stadt verliessen?
Sie war 18.
18?
- Ja.
Wie fühlt es sich an?
- Jetzt?
Du siehst doch,
sie weint vor Freude.
Arif und seine Frau Küscha
leben seit der Flucht in Baku.
Ihre Kinder und deren Partner
waren noch nie hier.
Aber auch ihre Gefühle sind gross
und werden live
an die Freunde in Baku gestreamt.
Der Ort ist inzwischen entmint.
In all den Ruinen fühlen sich
die Schlagen aber immer noch wohl.
Hast du gesehen?
Eine grosse Schlange.
Ich habe Angst.
Der Platz, zu dem sie mich führen,
scheint grossen symbolischen Wert
für die Stadt zu haben.
Wie soll ich das Video aufnehmen?
So oder lieber so?
Ich werde gleich eingespannt,
um ein Triumpf-Video
fürs Familienalbum zu machen.
Mir ist nicht ganz wohl
bei der Sache.
Ewige Ruhe für unsere Toten.
Hier haben sie gekämpft -
gegen die Russen und die Armenier.
Sie haben gewonnen.
Wir sind stolz
auf unsere gefallenen Soldaten.
Auf dem Platz
gab es früher Pferderennen,
Polospiele und Tanzaufführungen.
Auch Präsident Alijew
feierte hier den Sieg.
Ein schöner Ort zum Innehalten.
Ein Ort auch voller Legenden.
Man erzählt mir später,
dass die aserbaidschanischen Soldaten
vor zwei Jahren
hier hochgeklettert seien
und die Armenier Mann zu Mann
mit Messern getötet hätten.
Ich beginne zu zweifeln,
ob es hier trotz Sieg
viel Raum für Versöhnung gibt.
* Bedrückende Klänge *
Es gibt Historiker,
die auf die armenischen Ursprünge
der Stadt hinweisen.
Für andere,
wie dieses Lehrer-Ehepaar aus Baku,
ist es klar
eine aserbaidschanische Stadt.
Es gibt einige ausländische Medien,
die beweisen wollen,
dass Schuscha
eine armenische Stadt ist.
Karabach wurde 1752
von Panah Ali Khan gegründet.
Er war ein Aserbaidschaner
und kein Armenier.
Aber können die beiden Seiten
hier noch einmal zusammenleben?
Aserbaidschaner ...
- Unmöglich.
Die werden Schuscha nie wiedersehen.
Das ist unsere Stadt, unser Land.
Hier, sehen Sie, wir sind
in Schuscha und Sie filmen uns,
und so werden wir weiterleben.
Wir werden neu bauen.
Sie sehen dann,
was wir alles hier machen.
Schuscha wird wie Davos sein,
ich sag's Ihnen.
Wie Davos?
- Wie Davos, in der Schweiz.
Wir freuen uns,
dass Gerechtigkeit getan wurde.
Vielen Dank, dass ihr vom Schweizer
Fernsehen hier seid und das filmt.
Wir bedanken uns herzlich.
Karabach
ist und war immer Aserbaidschan.
Die Zeit ist knapp.
Küscha und ihr Sohn Elmar
stürmen weiter.
Das erste oder das zweite Haus?
- Das da.
Küscha wuchs hier in einem
der nun kaputten Wohnblocks auf.
Auf welcher Etage?
- Erster Stock.
Der Eintritt
kostet sie sichtlich Überwindung.
* Bedrückende Klänge *
Hat jemand in dieser Wohnung gelebt?
Ich weiss es nicht. Armenier ...
Küscha und ihre Familie
müssen nach Baku zurück.
Keiner kann mir sagen, wann
ehemalige Bewohnerinnen und Bewohner
in die Stadt zurückkehren dürfen.
Für die Verantwortlichen
stehen andere Pläne im Vordergrund.
Zwischen Ruinen aus dem ersten Krieg
und kaputten Wohnhäusern
aus dem zweiten werden
repräsentative Gebäude hochgezogen:
Hotels, Kongress- und Kulturzentren.
Schuscha ist für 2023
zur Kulturhauptstadt Aserbaidschans
und der türkischen Welt
ernannt worden.
Auch die grosse Kirche
wird renoviert.
Ein Affront
in den Augen der Armenier,
denn der Kirchturm
erhält ein Kuppeldach.
Als die Armenier noch hier waren,
hatte sie einen Spitzturm.
Die Geschichten der Rückkehrer
bewegen mich.
Aber mich verstört auch
der fehlende Wille zur Versöhnung,
und die Tatsache,
die Fehler nur beim Gegner zu sehen.
Ich bleibe in der Stadt und
besuche ein wiedereröffnetes Museum.
Ich hoffe,
hier differenziertere Antworten
auf die Geschichte
dieses Landstriches zu finden.
Der Museumsdirektor
empfängt uns freundlich.
Das Haus ist Bülbül gewidmet,
einem aserbaidschanischen Opernsänger
und Volkskünstler der Sowjetzeit,
der bis zu seinem Tod 1961
hier wohnte.
Bülbül ist ein Spitzname
und heisst Nachtigall.
Warum?
Hier gibt es einen Maulbeerbaum.
Er ist 151 Jahre alt.
Als Kind kletterte er da rauf
und imitierte Vögel.
Deshalb wurde er bei den Leuten
unter dem Namen Bülbül bekannt.
Nach dieser netten Geschichte
wird es wieder ernst.
Das ist Bülbüls Büste.
Sie wurde 1982 aufgestellt.
Die Armenier
haben sie so zugerichtet.
Wir bewahren sie auf,
damit künftige Generationen
den Vandalismus der Armenier
betrachten können.
* Sanfter Gesang *
Bülbül, die Nachtigall,
in einer Aufnahme von 1954.
Es gab ja verschiedene Zeiten -
mal haben die einen getötet,
mal die anderen,
und dann gab es auch Zeiten
des friedlichen Zusammenlebens.
Denken Sie, dass das hier
in Schuscha noch mal möglich ist?
Komm her!
Er wurde vor 67 Jahren
in Schuscha geboren
und lebte hier
vor der armenischen Besetzung.
Jetzt ist er
nach Schuscha zurückgekehrt
und hilft beim Wiederaufbau.
Er ist unser Freund,
wir arbeiten zusammen.
Er repariert unser Museum.
Hat irgendjemand
je etwas Böses gegen die Armenier
in Schuscha gesagt?
- Nie.
Sei ehrlich.
Die Armenier
waren immer gegen uns aggressiv.
Das sind Fakten.
Sie wurden während der Sowjetzeit
immer respektiert.
Wir haben uns in jeder Hinsicht
um sie gekümmert.
Eine Eisenbahnlinie wurde gebaut,
Gas geliefert,
Elektrizität während 24 Std.
Man hat sich umfassend
um sie gekümmert.
Sie aber haben nicht verstanden.
Sie begannen mit dem Krieg gegen uns
und forderten immer mehr.
Und heute, trotz allem, schauen
wir sie als unsere Bürger an -
wenn sie auf Rache verzichten,
auf der Idee,
das Resultat des Krieges umzukehren,
wenn sie
unsere Staatsbürgerschaft annehmen.
Armenier haben 150,
maximal 200 Jahre Geschichte hier.
Sie vergraben einen Stein,
dann graben sie ihn wieder aus
und sagen:
"Schaut, wir haben eine Geschichte
von 1'000 Jahren hier!"
Das ist etwas, das überhaupt nicht
zu unserem Charakter passt.
Wir würden uns das nie erlauben.
So etwas machen nur Armenier.
Solche Aussagen sind es,
die das EU-Parlament
in einer Resolution vom März 2022
verurteilt.
Es ruft beide Seiten - insbesondere
den Sieger Aserbaidschan - dazu auf,
das Kulturerbe und die Geschichte
des Gegners zu respektieren.
Wie nötig das ist, zeigt sich,
als ich den Direktor
auf das Massaker von 1920 anspreche,
das Aserbaidschaner
an den Armeniern verübten.
Damals wurde das armenische Viertel
der Stadt zerstört.
Bei dieser Frage mischt sich dann
auch unser Begleiter und Übersetzer
ein.
Es heisst doch,
dass es hier 1920 ein Pogrom gab.
(Übersetzer) Hier ein Pogrom?
- Die Armenier wurden ermordet.
Nein, hier wurde niemand umgebracht
und auch nicht vertrieben.
Er sagt hier wurden 1920
Armenier getötet und vertrieben.
Nein, nein, das war nicht so.
Ich weiss nicht, woher diese Angaben
kommen. Es war umgekehrt.
Die Aserbaidschaner verübten nie
ein Massaker an Armeniern.
Es gibt keinen einzelnen belegten
solchen Fall in der Geschichte.
Es gab Kämpfe und Kriege,
aber nie einen Genozid.
Spasibo.
* Sie sprechen russisch. *
So enden die Diskussionen
in dieser Gegend meistens:
Die Taten des Gegners
werden zu nationalen Dramen,
die eigenen Taten
werden abgestritten.
Ich schaue hinab auf Stepanakert.
Viele Armenier, die Schuscha
im Krieg verlassen mussten,
flüchteten
in den Hauptort von Bergkarabach.
Die Aserbaidschaner
nennen ihn Khankendi.
Überhaupt: In dieser Gegend ist es
für mich ein ständiger Eiertanz,
je nach Partei
die richtigen Ortsnamen zu nennen.
* Jubel *
2019 fand dort
ein Sportwettbewerb statt,
von dem wahrscheinlich die wenigsten
gehört haben: die CONIFA,
die Fussballeuropameisterschaft
der nicht anerkannten Staaten.
* Rhythmische Musik *
Teilgenommen haben Mannschaften
wie Sápmi, Tschameria,
Szeklerland oder Padanien.
Gastgeber war die Republik Arzach,
wie die Armenier Bergkarabach nennen.
Sieger war Südossetien, wo ich
auf dieser Reise auch noch hinmöchte.
* Jubel *
Ich möchte mit den Fussballern
von damals reden.
Viele von ihnen
haben im Krieg gekämpft.
Keine 10 km entfernt
liegt der Ort vor mir.
Eigentlich müsste ich
nur diese Strasse hinunterfahren,
aber das ist verboten.
Ich muss
einen irrwitzigen Umweg machen.
Der direkte Grenzübertritt
zwischen Aserbaidschan und Armenien
ist unmöglich.
Deshalb muss ich das Gebiet
auf aserbaidschanischer Seite
weitläufig umfahren,
um dann via Georgien
nach Armenien zu gelangen.
Von Armenien aus gibt es
einen Korridor nach Stepanakert,
der von den Russen überwacht wird.
Die einzige Möglichkeit,
dahin zu kommen.
In einer Welt ohne Grenzen würde
meine Reise ein paar Minuten dauern.
Ich rechne jetzt mit drei Tagen.
Immerhin gibt das
die Möglichkeit für Entdeckungen.
2 Std. von Schuscha entfernt
machen wir Halt beim
nigelnagelneuen Flughafen Füzuli.
Er erscheint mir
wie das Gegenteil von Berlin:
im Nullkommanichts ein fertiger
Flughafen, aber kaum Nachfrage.
In nur acht Monaten bauten ihn die
Aserbaidschaner mithilfe der Türkei
auf ehemals besetztem Gebiet.
Stolz zeigt mir der Direktor,
was für die Region
auf dem Reissbrett geplant ist.
Zuerst der Flughafen
und dann alles andere -
Landwirtschaft,
Industrie und v.a. Tourismus.
Jetzt, als Sieger,
fordern sie einen Friedensvertrag -
nach ihren Bedingungen.
Wir sind offen.
Wir wollen eine friedliche Verein-
barung mit Armenien unterschreiben.
Unser Präsident
spricht davon im Fernsehen.
Wir möchten
normale Beziehungen führen,
wir möchten
eine normale Entwicklung der Region.
Aber Sie sehen, es rührt sich
bis jetzt nichts vom Fleck.
Zwei weitere Flughäfen
sind bereits in Planung.
Wo die genau zu liegen kommen,
möchte ich wissen.
Das ist eine falsche Karte.
Falsch?
Sie wurde vor zwei Jahren
herausgegeben. Was ist falsch?
Es gibt kein Bergkarabach,
es gibt nur Karabach.
Ich glaube, wir in der Schweiz
haben noch keine neuen Karten.
Ich habe diese
in der Schweiz gekauft.
Man muss in Baku eine Karte kaufen.
Können Sie es nochmals
auf der Karte zeigen?
Hier drauf darf man nicht zeigen.
Mit diesem Namen nicht.
Ich werde hier nichts zeigen,
wenn Sie filmen.
Alles klar.
Nagorno-Karabach,
Karabach, Bergkarabach, Arzach -
schwierig,
den Überblick zu behalten.
Auch, wo man durchfahren darf.
Maroka.
Marokko?
- Nein, nicht Marokko, Maroka.
Das bedeutet Kopfschmerz.
Du musst da hin und dann da ...
Warum können wir da nicht durch?
Sind da die Friedenstruppen?
- Ja, da sind Friedenstruppen.
Hier sind russische Friedenstruppen,
man braucht eine Bewilligung.
Ich lerne: Auch für die Durchfahrt
in dem von Aserbaidschan
befreiten Gebiet braucht es offenbar
die Bewilligung der Russen.
Schwer zu durchschauen das Ganze.
Wir wollten alles korrekt
und legal machen.
Aber schon
bei der Organisation der Reise
hatten wir so viel Klärungsbedarf,
dass wir im Vorfeld
den aserbaidschanischen Botschafter
in Bern besuchten.
Hello, Mr Ambassador.
- Nice to see you.
Nice to meet you.
- You are very welcome.
Auf die Frage
nach den Bewilligungen der Russen
gerät auch er ins Schlingern.
Können wir von Schuscha
nach Khankendi?
Dieser Teil des Territoriums
wird geschützt.
Wissen Sie,
es handelt sich um sogenanntes ...
russische Friedenstruppen
sind da auf speziellen Posten.
Und deshalb müssen wir mit ihnen
in Kontakt sein,
wie Sie reisen können.
Und das ist der Grund,
weshalb es etwas kompliziert ist.
"Etwas kompliziert"
bedeutet jetzt für mich
die Kleinigkeit
von rund 1'000 km Umweg.
* Christof Franzen
summt ein Lied vor sich hin. *
Hast du all die Porträts links
gesehen, Lisa?
Die Autobahn ist gesäumt
von Porträts gefallener
aserbaidschanischer Soldaten.
Das Ziel erreiche ich nur
mit zwei Grenzübertritten:
Zuerst nach Georgien,
auf quasi neutrales Territorium,
wo wir das Auto
und den Fahrer wechseln.
Aj, aj, aj.
Man merkt, wir befinden uns
auf der Seidenstrasse.
Ein riesiges
wirtschaftliches Potenzial,
aber viele ungelöste Probleme.
Die sich ewig stauenden Lastwagen
scheinen mir wie ein Symbol dafür.
Georgien sieht einladend aus.
Wir werden später
wieder hierher zurückkommen.
Aber jetzt
fahren wir erst nach Armenien.
Wir fürchten noch,
dass es Probleme geben könnte,
da unser Pass jetzt
ein aserbaidschanisches Visum hat.
Aber der Grenzübertritt
verläuft reibungslos.
Wieder braucht es auf der anderen
Seite einen Fahrerwechsel.
Im bergigen Armenien
leben 3 Mio. Einwohner.
Zudem gibt es
7 Mio. Armenierinnen und Armenier,
die irgendwo
verstreut auf der Welt leben.
Armenien ist das erste Land,
das das Christentum
zur Staatskirche gemacht hat.
Die Menschen machen mich aufmerksam
auf ihre Kulturdenkmäler,
und sie sind stolz
auf ihre uralte Siedlungsgeschichte.
Ich zünde eine Kerze an
für den Frieden.
Bevor wir weiter zu den Fussballern
von Bergkarabach fahren,
machen wir Halt
in der Hauptstadt Jerewan.
Dort haben wir eine Begegnung, die
uns erst mal zum Schmunzeln bringt.
* Insektensummen *
* Aufschrei *
* Scheppern *
Das Märchen erzählt die Geschichte,
wie sich alle
um einen Tropfen Honig streiten.
* Schmerzensschreie *
* Applaus *
Bravo!
Spasibo.
- (Frau) Wow! Very nice.
Und so töten sich
zuerst die Menschen aller Dörfer,
dann aller Städte
und dann der ganzen Welt -
und alles nur
wegen eines Tropfen Honigs.
Wenn es um Krieg geht,
weiss Nver, wovon er spricht:
Der Puppenspieler und seine Familie
mussten vor zwei Jahren
aus Schuschi - wie man Schuscha
hier nennt - fliehen.
In Schuschi hatten sie gemeinsam
mit anderen ein Puppentheater.
* Verspielte Musik *
Sie mussten aber alles zurücklassen -
und verloren noch viel mehr.
Ich musste 18 Nummern
aus meinem Handy löschen.
Menschen, mit denen ich
direkt in Kontakt stand.
Es gibt Leute,
die alles verloren haben.
Deshalb denke ich, es ist unmöglich,
mit der aserbaidschanischen Nation
zusammenzuleben.
Ich glaube nicht,
dass sie sich ändern werden.
Wir lehren unseren Kindern
nicht dasselbe,
was sie ihren Kindern lehren.
Wir lehren unsere nicht,
ihr Land zu besetzen.
Wir sagen ihnen:
"Ihr müsst stark sein,
damit ihr euch verteidigen könnt."
Aber sie sagen ihren Kindern:
"Ihr müsst stark sein,
um Armenier zu töten und
unser Territorium zurückzuerobern."
Das ist der Unterschied.
Die beiden haben zwei Kinder,
sechs und acht Jahre alt.
Wie geht es den Kindern jetzt hier?
Vermissen sie ihr Zuhause noch?
Vor etwa zwei Monaten
fragte mein Sohn,
ob wir für ihn
ein Fernglas kaufen könnten.
Wir verstanden nicht, warum, und
warum es so ein gutes sein musste.
Dann sagte er:
"Ihr versteht das nicht."
"Ich muss nach Stepanakert gehen und
will von da nach Schuschi schauen."
Nver stellt jetzt Schattenspiele her
und will sie an Eltern verkaufen.
Er liebt seinen Beruf, aber im Krieg
tauge der nichts, meint er.
Nver kämpfte in der Artillerie
und gewann sogar
eine Tapferkeitsmedaille.
Unsere ganze Nation ist eine Armee.
Das ist unser erster Beruf,
ein Soldat zu sein.
Ich war nervös, ich hatte Angst.
Aber ich war gleichzeitig
auch stolz,
als mein Mann in den Krieg zog.
Es ist der Kampf um unsere Existenz.
Wenn wir kämpfen müssen,
nur um zu leben,
dann denken wir nicht daran,
was danach kommt.
Ich werde auch nicht dagegen sein,
wenn mein Sohn in den Kampf will.
Wir suchen den Kampf nicht,
aber wenn es ihn braucht,
dann kämpfen wir.
Und wenn unser Sohn
irgendwann z.B. in den Krieg muss,
um Schuschi zurückzuholen,
die Heimat,
den Ort,
wo sein Grossvater geboren wurde,
dann kann ich ihn
nicht zurückhalten.
Das Lebensgefühl vieler Armenier
ist das eines bedrohten Volkes.
Tief im historischen Bewusstsein
verankert
ist ihre Vertreibung
aus dem Osmanischen Reich.
Dem Vertreibungs-
und Vernichtungskrieg der Türken
fielen 1915 und 1916 bis zu 1,5 Mio.
Armenierinnen und Armenier zum Opfer.
Viele Nationen anerkennen
dieses Massaker heute als Völkermord.
Ich habe den Eindruck, dass sich
die Karabach-Frage für viele Armenier
in ein altes Gefühl
der ständigen Bedrohung einreiht.
Ein Kampf, bei dem sie
auf Russland angewiesen sind.
Wie stellen Sie sich
die Zukunft vor,
wenn die russischen Friedenstruppen
weggehen sollten?
Ehrlich gesagt, kann ich mir
nicht vorstellen, was dann passiert.
Obwohl sie da sind, geraten beide
Seiten immer wieder aneinander.
Die Aserbaidschaner
lassen keine Gelegenheit aus,
uns in Schwierigkeiten zu bringen:
Einmal kappen sie den Strom,
ein anderes Mal die Gasleitung ...
Wenn die russischen Friedenswächter
nicht da wären,
würden solche Dinge
noch öfter passieren
und wir würden
zum Krieg zurückkehren.
Wir machen uns endlich auf
zum armenisch kontrollierten Teil
von Bergkarabach -
zumindest so weit wir dürfen.
Von Jerewan fahren wir
nach Goris im Südosten des Landes.
Dahinter
beginnt der sog. Latschin-Korridor,
der von den Russen gesichert wird.
Diese Strasse
ist die einzige Verbindung
in den armenisch kontrollierten Teil
von Bergkarabach.
Doch der Botschafter
von Aserbaidschan hatte uns gewarnt,
von hier aus
die Grenze zu überqueren.
Von Armenien
nach Bergkarabach zu gehen -
das ist verboten.
- Das ist verboten.
Wenn wir von da aus gehen, dann
haben wir ein Problem mit Ihnen.
Ja, wenn Sie von Armenien aus gehen,
haben Sie ein Problem mit uns.
Denn Sie sollten nicht auf
unser Territorium ohne Erlaubnis.
Es ist unser Territorium.
Das ist normal für alle Länder.
Es geht nicht nur um uns.
Es gibt da auch Friedenswächter.
Sie sind instruiert,
nur Armenier durchzulassen.
Ich kannte die neuste Situation
eben nicht.
Ich hoffte, wenn es jetzt ein
Übereinkommen gäbe, wäre es offen.
Es ist nicht offen.
Wir haben kein Friedensabkommen.
Wenn Sie mich fragen -
ich sage es auf Russisch:
Schaden Sie uns nicht!
Tun Sie nichts,
was diesen Prozess der Friedens-
verhandlungen gefährden könnte.
Schritt für Schritt.
Jetzt hat eben der Prozess
zwischen Armenien und Aserbaidschan
angefangen.
Ich bitte Sie.
Es ist sehr wichtig, dieses kleine
Pflänzchen am Leben zu erhalten.
Wir sind keine Armenier
und wollen auch nicht auf die
schwarze Liste der Aserbaidschaner.
Deshalb ist für uns hier Schluss.
Aber die Fahrt ist nicht umsonst.
Drei der armenischen Fussballer
aus dem Team Bergkarabach
haben sich bereit erklärt,
uns entgegenzukommen
und uns beim Checkpoint zu treffen.
Hallo. Sprecht ihr russisch?
Christof.
* Sie sprechen russisch. *
Filmt nicht in diese Richtung.
Nur da hin, nicht da.
Seid ihr extra gekommen?
- Ja.- Danke.
Wie ist die Stimmung allgemein
in Stepanakert?
In Stepanakert geht's gut.
Das Leben dort geht weiter.
Und die Probleme
mit dem fehlenden Gas im Frühling?
Wie soll ich sagen?
Wir hatten schon immer Probleme,
und wir werden auch in Zukunft
Probleme haben - wie überall.
Ihr habt doch bei euch
auch Probleme.
Aber die Aserbaidschaner,
eure Feinde -
oder ich weiss nicht,
wie ich sie nennen soll -,
die sind doch jetzt viel näher.
Ja, sie sind viel näher, aber
im Moment sind wir in Sicherheit,
v.a. verglichen
mit der Situation im Krieg.
Aber nichts ist garantiert.
Wir sind
aus Aserbaidschan angereist.
Wer? Ihr?
- Ja, wir waren dort.
Wenn wir die Leute dort fragten,
wie sie die Zukunft von Khankendi
sehen würden, wie sie dort sagen ...
- Und, was sagen sie?
Sie sagen,
die Menschen können bleiben,
aber sie müssen einen
aserbaidschanischen Pass haben,
Bürger Aserbaidschans werden.
Das ist doch nicht realistisch.
Das wird es nicht geben.
Sie wollen das.
Aber dann müssen sie hören:
Das wird es nicht geben.
Solange wir hier sind.
Was würden Sie davon halten,
wenn ein Mensch
in diesem Krieg gefallen ist,
und der Vater
muss den Pass des Staates bekommen,
der seinen Sohn getötet hat?
Was würden Sie dazu sagen?
Jeder normale Mensch
würde das nicht akzeptieren.
Zumindest die Angehörigen
derjenigen Menschen,
die im Krieg getötet wurden,
werden das nicht akzeptieren.
Deshalb ist es nicht realistisch.
Ich denke sogar,
sie sagen das nur so,
aber sie wollen in Wahrheit
auch nicht mit uns leben.
Weder sie noch wir.
Wie muss man sich
die Strecke vorstellen?
Hier ist ja der erste Posten -
und wie sieht es danach aus?
Die Strasse geht so weiter.
Da sind einfach
russische Friedenstruppen.
Wir zeigen ihnen unseren Pass.
Da steht das Auto,
mit dem wir zurückfahren können.
Das müssen wir nehmen,
sonst kommen wir nicht mehr heim.
Tschüss, und danke vielmals.
* Sie sprechen russisch. *
Spasibo.
So schnell sie gekommen sind,
sind sie auch wieder weg.
Ich bin gar nicht dazu gekommen,
mit ihnen über den Krieg zu reden.
Gerne wäre ich mit ihnen mitgefahren.
Wir dürfen nicht mal
den Checkpoint filmen.
Zum Glück haben wir eine Armenierin
im Team, die für uns hinreist -
nach Arzach, wie die Armenier
Bergkarabach nennen.
Ein Gebiet fast gleich gross
wie der Kanton Waadt.
Unsere Kollegin
bringt uns Bilder von Stepanakert,
der Hauptstadt
des selbst ernannten Staates.
Er wird von niemandem anerkannt,
nicht mal
vom grossen Bruder Armenien.
Das, obwohl hier
nach den beiden Kriegen 1994 und 2020
praktisch nur noch Armenier wohnen.
Völkerrechtlich
gehört das Gebiet zu Aserbaidschan.
Unsere Kollegin trifft
die Fussballer vom Checkpoint wieder.
Die komplizierte Situation
spiegelt sich auch auf dem Rasen:
Sie spielen nicht nur
als Nationalteam von Arzach,
sondern nehmen auch an den Spielen
der armenischen Liga teil.
Weil aber niemand zu ihnen kann,
haben sie nur Auswärtsspiele.
Praktisch die gesamte Mannschaft
kämpfte im Krieg von 2020.
Sie hatten Glück:
Niemand ist umgekommen.
Aber Sicherheit, so sagen sie,
gebe es hier nicht.
Tatsächlich:
Nur wenige Monate nach unserem Besuch
kommt es zu neuen Kämpfen,
diesmal auf armenischem Boden.
Dabei sollen armenische
Kriegsgefangene ermordet worden sein.
Internationale Organisationen
werfen Aserbaidschan
grobe Kriegsverbrechen vor.
Und die Friedenstruppen?
Es ist offen, ob Russland
stark und willens genug ist,
den Frieden wirklich zu sichern.
Wir verlassen die Grenzregion und
fahren zurück Richtung Hauptstadt.
Während wir unterwegs
Landschaftsaufnahmen machen,
führe ich das wohl kürzeste Interview
meines Lebens.
Reicht es fürs Leben?
- Nein.
Dann schlägt
mein Journalistenradar aus
und zieht mich in das Dorf
am Fusse des Hügels.
Dort wartet bestimmt
eine spektakuläre Begegnung auf mich.
* Bohrmaschinendröhnen *
Hallo.
Wie geht's?
- Gut.
Schau, da unten ist mein Bruder.
Wir sind aus der Schweiz.
Wir sind gerade vorbeigefahren
und haben das Dorf gefilmt.
Wollt ihr einen Tee?
Danke.
Ihr macht gute Arbeit
in der Schweiz.
Das habe ich dort gesehen.
Ich war auch schon da. In Genf.
Was haben Sie gemacht?
Massage.
Ich bin ein schlauer Armenier.
Hallo, wie geht's?
- Gut.
Ist das Ihr Haus?
- Ja, mein Elternhaus.
Wieso wollten Sie denn
in die Schweiz?
Sie haben ja alles.
Ich habe auch in Spanien gelebt.
Die Politik hier ist dreckig.
Du möchtest z.B. etwas aufbauen.
Dann kommen sie zu dir und sagen:
"Hallo, wer ist dein Bruder?"
Waren Sie im Krieg?
Ja. Ich habe alles dafür im Haus.
Komm ins Haus, ich zeige dir alles.
Wir in der Schweiz
haben auch Gewehre im Haus,
wenn wir in der Armee sind.
Aber bei mir ist es illegal,
bei euch ist es legal.
Darf man hier
die Waffe nicht zu Hause haben?
Es ist illegal,
weil hier das Regime von Putin ist.
Ah, das Putin-Regime.
Aber ich arbeite im Moment
wirklich daran,
das Land
von diesem Dreck zu befreien.
Komm, ich zeige dir,
wie man bei uns die Kartoffeln brät.
Ich esse kein Fleisch.
Die Kartoffeln werden in einem
typisch armenischen Ofen gebacken.
Wie ist die Situation im Land?
Sehr schlecht.
Schau, wenn du selbst
nichts entscheiden kannst,
an deiner Stelle entscheidet
ein anderer - wie wäre das für dich?
Du hast ein Haus, eine Familie,
aber es entscheidet ein anderer.
Bei uns entscheidet alles Russland.
Was sind wir für ein Land?
Russland trifft die Entscheidungen
im Bereich Sicherheit.
Welche Sicherheit?
Siehst du etwa, dass die Menschen
hier in Sicherheit sind?
Sag ehrlich, sind die Einheimischen
hier in Sicherheit?
Ich weiss nicht.
- Ich weiss das.
Nein, sie sind nicht in Sicherheit.
Das ist eine lange Geschichte.
Lass uns Tee trinken.
Möchten Sie,
dass Armenien näher zu Europa ist?
Aber natürlich.
Wie kann man das nicht wollen?
Europa ist das Leben.
Im Haus
erwarten mich neue Überraschungen.
(Frau) Sie sind zu Hause
beim Hauptrevolutionär Armeniens.
Das sind
die Patrioten unseres Landes.
Was ist das für eine Partei?
Revolutionspartei?
Das sind Revolutionäre,
und er ist einer davon.
Haben Sie an den letzten Wahlen
teilgenommen?- Natürlich.
Wie viele Stimmen
haben Sie bekommen?
Nicht nichts, aber wenige,
weil wir ja Revolutionäre sind.
Wenn Putin nicht kontrolliert hätte,
gäbe es mehr Stimmen.
Welche Revolution ist es bei euch?
Kommunistische
oder nationalistische?
Nicht nationalistische,
sondern nationale.
Ich sehe Feuer in Ihren Augen.
Ich bin eine Künstlerin,
ich bin Opernsängerin.
Haben Sie Auftritte?
Seit zehn Jahren
trete ich nirgendwo auf,
weder im Theater noch im Konzert.
Aber manchmal
haben wir einzelne Vorführungen.
Wir werden zum Abendessen eingeladen.
Es gibt Vitamine und Wodka.
Hier ein Schweizer Messer.
Ich habe leider nichts
für den Tisch dabei.
Das macht nichts. Wir haben alles.
Und was wir gar nicht wollen,
ist Geld.
Ich möchte hier
sogar ein Dorf aufbauen,
in dem es gar kein Geld gibt.
"Da, wo kein Geld,
da kein Schweizer",
so heisst ein Sprichwort.
Unser Fahrer, der ebenfalls im Krieg
war, ist natürlich auch dabei
und stimmt die Takte
eines armenischen Liebesliedes an.
* Die Frau stimmt ins Lied mit ein. *
* Sanfter Gesang *
Bravo! Bravo!
Spasibo.
- Spasibo.
Vielen Dank.
Ich hatte Tränen in den Augen.
Vielen Dank und auf Wiedersehen.
Ich komme noch mit zum Auto.
Ist das Ihr Neffe?
- Ein Nachbarskind.
Er sagt,
das seien alles seine Kinder.
Die zukünftigen Revolutionäre.
Nette Leute, diese Revolutionäre.
Aber als ich dann auf dem Rückweg
google, stellt sich heraus,
dass mein Che Guevara
alles andere als harmlos ist.
Zwei Jahre sass er in Haft
wegen Geiselnahme
und illegalem Waffenbesitz.
Er und seine Gruppe, die streng
antirussisch ausgerichtet ist,
besetzten einen Polizeiposten
und es gab drei Tote.
Wegen Mordes wurden aber nur
zwei seiner Mitstreiter angeklagt.
Kurz nach meiner Rückkehr
in die Schweiz erfahre ich,
dass er offenbar
wieder festgenommen wurde.
Der wilde Kaukasus -
die Realität
übertrifft manchmal das Klischee.
In Armenien gibt es laute Stimmen,
die
mit dem Waffenstillstandsabkommen,
das die Russen vermittelt haben,
gar nicht einverstanden sind.
Im Archiv finde ich Bilder, wie sich
der Zorn der Menschen entlädt,
als der Premierminister
das Ende der Kämpfe
gegen Aserbaidschan bekannt gibt.
Die aufgebrachte Menge
ist der Meinung,
Armenien hätte nicht aufgeben dürfen.
* Die Frau spricht armenisch. *
Als wir im Mai 2022 in Armenien sind,
hat sich die Opposition seit Wochen
auf dem Platz des Friedens in Jerewan
fest eingerichtet.
Sie wirft der Regierung Schwäche vor.
Doch welchen Handlungsspielraum
hat Armenien, frage ich mich.
Im Vorfeld der Reise besuchte ich
nicht nur den aserbaidschanischen,
sondern auch
den armenischen Botschafter, in Genf.
Ich will von ihm wissen,
wie er die Situation nach
der Niederlage im Krieg einschätzt.
Ich nehme an,
es hat Armenien schwer getroffen.
Wissen Sie, in unserer Region
sind wir so sehr an Kriege
und Unsicherheiten gewohnt,
dass es fast Teil unseres Alltags
geworden ist.
Natürlich
machen wir uns grosse Sorgen.
Die Menschen
verstehen den Ernst der Situation.
Wir fühlen uns sehr verletzlich
in diesem Teil der Welt.
Aber da leben wir,
das ist unsere Geografie
und wir haben
eine gewisse Gewöhnung damit.
Der Status von Bergkarabach
ist natürlich sehr wichtig.
Wie ist die offizielle Position
im Moment?
Akzeptieren Sie Bergkarabach
als Teil Aserbaidschans
mit einem speziellen Status,
oder geht es immer noch
um Unabhängigkeit?
Oder ist das zu schwierig zu sagen?
Ich denke, dass die Menschheit
bis zu diesem 21. Jahrhundert
einen langen Weg gegangen ist
mit der Entwicklung
der Menschenrechte
und der fundamentalen Freiheiten,
die die internationalen
Organisationen eingeführt haben.
Deshalb sollte die entscheidende
Stimme denjenigen gegeben werden,
die direkt betroffen sind.
Wenn Sie nach meiner Meinung fragen:
Die Menschen von Bergkarabach
sollten das letzte Wort haben.
Armenien ist im Gegensatz
zu Aserbaidschan eine Demokratie.
Der Vorschlag ist aber
nicht nur deswegen nachvollziehbar.
Da Bergkarabach praktisch nur noch
von Armenierinnen und Armeniern
bewohnt wird,
wäre das Ergebnis einer Abstimmung
sicher zugunsten Armeniens.
Aserbaidschan hat aber das Völker-
recht auf seiner Seite, das besagt,
die Grenzen der alten Sowjet-
republiken seien zu respektieren -
und da gehörte Bergkarabach
zu Aserbaidschan.
Doch wie sind die Grenzen
zustande gekommen?
Der armenische Botschafter
hat dazu eine klare Meinung.
Als die Sowjetunion
1921 gegründet wurde,
entschied die Zentralregierung
in Moskau zuerst,
Bergkarabach in die armenische
Sowjetrepublik einzugliedern,
und Aserbaidschan fand das gut.
Es gibt historische Dokumente dazu.
Und dann, plötzlich, über Nacht,
entschieden sie,
dass es zu Aserbaidschan gehört.
Aber das war natürlich illegal.
Die Grenzen während der Sowjetzeit
waren hauptsächlich
administrativer Art.
Es gab keine offiziellen Grenzen,
es war ja ein grosses Imperium.
Als die Sowjetunion kollabierte,
beanspruchte Aserbaidschan
weiterhin dieses Gebiet für sich.
So begann der Konflikt.
Wie der Konflikt tatsächlich begann,
ist umstritten.
Wann er enden wird - unabsehbar.
Jetzt gibt es wieder
Friedensgespräche
zwischen Armenien und Aserbaidschan,
unter der Regie der EU.
Der Kreml
begrüsst offiziell dieses Bemühen,
aber wie stark er sich für einen
Frieden engagieren wird, ist offen.
Gerne nutzt er Konflikte
in den sowjetischen Nachfolgestaaten,
um sich im ehemaligen Hoheitsgebiet
Kontrolle und Einfluss zu sichern.
Wir sind auf unserer Reise
inzwischen in Georgien angekommen.
Hier hat es
nicht nur einen Konfliktherd,
in dem die Russen mitmischen,
sondern zwei.
Abchasien hat sich
nach dem Zerfall der Sowjetunion
in einem hässlichen Bürgerkrieg
von Georgien losgesagt.
Ein weiterer Krieg 2008
spaltete Südossetien ab.
Und um es gleich vorwegzunehmen:
Nein, ich komme nicht
nach Südossetien rein.
Man hat uns gleich gesagt,
von Georgien her sei das chancenlos.
Höchstens von russischer Seite her,
mit Spezialbewilligung.
Und auch in die sog. Konfliktzone
geht es nur mit Polizeigeleit.
Begleiten wird uns dabei ein -
wie mir scheint -
etwas entwurzelter Held.
Er wohnt nur wenige Kilometer
von Südossetien entfernt.
Guten Tag.
Das ist unser Haus.
Das hat der Staat für uns gekauft.
Es ist neu.
Hallo.
Das ist mein Sohn.
Wie heisst er?
- Georgi.
Der zweite Sohn, sagt mir Malkhaz,
sei gerade unterwegs.
Warum haben Sie
dieses Haus bekommen?
Ich bin Flüchtling.
Ich musste weg.
Aus Ossetien?
- Ja.
Ich konnte nicht mehr
im Haus dort leben.
Wegen des Krieges?
Als der Krieg ausgebrochen ist,
war ich in Wladikawkas, in Russland.
Als ich vier Jahre später zurückkam,
war hier schon die Grenze.
Was sehe ich da: eine Grenze.
Man hat mir gesagt,
da hätten die russischen Truppen
eine russische Grenzzone
abgeriegelt.
Das gehöre jetzt zu Südossetien.
Ich sage, das ist doch Georgien -
nicht Ossetien, nicht Russland,
das ist doch Georgien.
Aber was soll man tun?
Jetzt
sind die russischen Soldaten da.
Eine Weile
war die Grenze für Anwohner
noch einigermassen durchlässig.
So hat Malkhaz auch seine Frau auf
der georgischen Seite kennengelernt.
Aber sie zu besuchen,
war ihm plötzlich verboten.
Sie schnappten mich, als ich
die Grenze unerlaubt überschritt.
Aber wie kann man denn
die Grenze überschreiten?
Da gibt es doch Stacheldraht.
Ich bin draufgetreten
und bin rübergegangen.
Dort gibt es einen Grenzposten,
die haben das gesehen.
Die Grenztruppen
haben mich festgenommen
und zu ihrer Hütte gebracht.
Dann haben sie
das ossetische KGB angerufen.
Die KGB-Leute haben mich abgeholt
und zu sich gebracht.
Mussten Sie ein paar Tage in Haft?
- Ja, ich bin im Keller gesessen.
Mit Gittern.
Ich wusste nicht, wo ich war.
Ich war allein.
Wie haben sie sich
Ihnen gegenüber verhalten?
Haben sie Sie geschlagen
oder bedroht?
Ja, getreten und geschlagen.
Die Osseten und die Russen wollten,
dass ich für sie spioniere,
für das KGB.
Aber das würde ich nie machen.
Als Agent?
Dass ich Namen, Telefonnummern usw.
von den georgischen Polizisten
für sie besorge.
Aber ich mache so was nicht,
und ich werde so was nie tun.
Darum konnte ich nicht mehr in
meinem Haus bleiben und kam hierher.
Seit gut einem Jahr lebt Malkhaz nun
mit seiner Familie
auf georgischer Seite.
Die georgische Regierung war
wahrscheinlich so grosszügig mit ihm,
weil sein Grossvater
Heldenstatus hatte.
Der Präsident Georgiens
hatte ihm eine Medaille überreicht.
Was ist das für ein Orden?
Wofür?
Für seinen Mut und sein Heldentum.
Malkhaz' Grosseltern
gehörten zu den wenigen Georgiern,
die trotz der Niederlage nach dem
Krieg in Südossetien geblieben waren.
Südossetien 2008.
Nachdem sich
südossetische Separatisten
dieser Provinz schon 1992 von
Georgien unabhängig erklärt hatten,
entluden sich die Spannungen
und Provokationen
in einem handfesten Krieg.
Die Russen schickten Militärhilfe
durch den Tunnel
unter den kaukasischen Bergen durch.
Dank dieser militärischen Übermacht
gewannen die Südosseten den Krieg
in nur fünf Tagen.
Tausende Menschen georgischer
Abstammung mussten fliehen.
Die Südosseten freuten sich -
mit den Flaggen der beiden Sieger,
wie nach einem
gewonnenen Fussballmatch.
* Er spricht russisch. *
* Hupen, Schüsse *
Für die internationale Gemeinschaft
ist Südossetien
immer noch ein Teil Georgiens.
Russland hingegen anerkannte
bereits wenige Tage nach dem Sieg
die Unabhängigkeit und hat seinen
Einfluss seither massiv verstärkt.
Nelly, unsere georgische Übersetzerin
und Begleiterin,
kennt die Situation hier gut.
Wie nennt ihr diese Linie hier?
- Konfliktlinie.
Konfliktlinie, nicht Grenze.
Nein. Grenze haben wir mit Russland.
Wir nennen das auch
eine "schleichende Besetzung",
weil sie ihren Zaun immer wieder
verschieben, Stück für Stück.
Wie weit? So 10 m oder so?
Am Morgen ist er 15 m weiter,
tags darauf nochmals 20 m.
Läuft das immer noch so?
- Ja. Eine schleichende Besetzung.
Gehen wir deine Oma besuchen.
Malkhaz ist bei den Grosseltern
in Südossetien aufgewachsen.
Der Grossvater
ist inzwischen gestorben,
aber die Grossmutter lebt noch.
Als Mitbringsel für die Oma: Wasser.
Die Konfliktlinie
ist nur fünf Autominuten entfernt.
Hier sind wir bei der Linie.
Gleich werde ich Zeuge,
was Politik
für die Menschen bedeuten kann.
Dort hinten
geht es zum Haus meiner Grossmutter.
Der Stacheldraht scheint völlig
willkürlich ins Land gesetzt,
mitten durch private Grundstücke.
Hier spreche ich normalerweise
mit ihr,
Aber nur mit der Polizei.
Ich habe Angst vor denen,
dass sie über den Zaun springen
und mich fangen.
Ich habe euch etwas gebracht.
Hast du keine Bohnen mehr,
die ich einpflanzen kann?
Ich habe noch Platz im Garten.
Komm her!
Halt das mal.
(Angestrengt) Ui!
- Wirf es einfach.
Einfach werfen?
Geht es?
Süssigkeiten.
Wie geht es?
- Der Kopf tut mir weh.
Haben Sie Medikamente?
Nein.
Geben Sie es dem Kind.
Sie geben sie zurück.
Der Enkel hat ein neues Haus.
Möchten Sie nicht umziehen?
Nein, will ich nicht.
Sonst nehmen all das hier
die Russen.
Es sind Russen gekommen
und haben gesagt:
"Wieso gehst du nicht?"
Ich sagte:
"Habt ihr das hier gebaut?
Na dann haut ab!"
Können Sie ohne ihn leben?
Ich habe ihn aufgezogen,
seit er so klein war.
Er bringt mir immer Essen,
sonst würde ich hungrig bleiben.
Da drüben gibt es Wasser,
bei mir nicht.
Ich kann es nicht selbst holen
wegen diesem da.
Die Grossmutter
hat einen kleinen Acker.
Und da sie für Georgien
immer noch als Bürgerin gilt,
bekommt sie auch eine kleine Rente.
Der Enkel
profitiert wohl auch noch davon.
Wo kommt ihr her?
- Aus der Schweiz.
Ist das Richtung Russland?
Nein, Schweiz ist nicht Russland.
Das ist was anderes.
Ich danke euch, Bruder.
- Danke Ihnen, Schwester.
Alles Gute und gute Schwangerschaft.
Bleib gesund, Oma.
Ich danke dir.
* Melancholische Musik *
Südossetien könnte als
eigenständiges Land nicht überleben.
Für die rund 50'000 Menschen,
die hinter diesem Stacheldraht leben,
ist
laut dem südossetischen Präsidenten
eine sog. stärkere Integration
in Russland geplant.
Darüber, wie die genau aussehen soll,
dringt nichts nach aussen.
Tiflis oder auch Tbilissi,
die Hauptstadt Georgiens -
keine zwei Fahrstunden
vom Zaun entfernt.
* Sehnsüchtige Musik *
Es ist nicht zu übersehen:
Georgien hat den Drang nach Europa,
v.a. die Jungen.
Heute ist Tag der Unabhängigkeit.
Alles, was im Land
Rang und Namen hat,
macht sich bereit
für die grosse Militärparade.
* Lautsprecherdurchsage
auf Georgisch *
Die pro-europäische Rede
der Präsidentin Salome Surabischwili
wird im ganzen Land
live im Fernsehen übertragen.
Bestärkt wird die Rede mit der
"Ode an die Freude", der Europahymne.
* Pompöser Gesang *
# Freude, schöner Götterfunken,
Tochter aus Elysium.
# Wir betreten feuertrunken,
Himmlische, dein Heiligtum.
Auf mich wirkt die Rede
wie ein eindringlicher Appell,
denn es gibt im Land
nicht nur Europa-Freunde.
Der Premierminister
gilt als Günstling
eines georgischen,
Russland-freundlichen Oligarchen.
So lehnen er und seine Partei
z.B. Sanktionen gegen Russland ab.
Aber ich höre in der Rede
auch einen Appell an die EU.
Und trotzdem:
Einige Wochen später wird Georgien
der EU-Kandidatenstatus verweigert.
Das treibt während Wochen
Zehntausende von Menschen in Tiflis
auf die Strasse.
Sie fürchten, dass sich die ersehnte
Tür nach Europa wieder schliesst.
Fraglich ist aber, ob die EU
Georgien näher an sich bindet,
solange die Reformbemühungen stocken
und vom Kreml gesteuerte ungelöste
territoriale Konflikte herrschen.
* Handyklingeln *
(Frau) Hallo
- Guten Tag.
Ja, ich höre Sie.
Hier ist Christof Franzen
vom Schweizer Fernsehen.
Was möchten Sie?
Ich wollte nachfragen
wegen des Einreisevisums.
Über welche Grenze
möchten Sie fahren?
Von Georgien aus.
Diese Grenze ist seit 2020 zu.
Man weiss nicht,
wann sie wieder offen ist.
In dieser Saison wohl nicht mehr.
Also ganz zu?
- Ja, ganz.
Ist das noch wegen Covid?
Ja, ja.
Und über Russland?
Wir haben russische Visa?
Über Russland kann man,
aber das entscheiden nicht wir.
Fragen Sie die russischen Behörden.
Dann erhalten Sie
je nach Antwort unsere Visa.
Wir müssen also zuerst Russland
um Erlaubnis fragen?
Ja, genau.
Ich hatte mich schon Monate zuvor
um ein Visum nach Abchasien bemüht.
Ein weiterer eingefrorener Konflikt
um einen selbst ernannten Kleinstaat,
der sich mithilfe der Russen
anfangs 90er-Jahre abgespalten hat.
Immer wurde ich vertröstet.
Hiermit ist meine letzte Chance,
verbotenes Land
vor der Haustür Europas zu betreten,
gegen null gesunken.
Aber noch gebe ich nicht ganz auf.
Ich fahre trotzdem in Richtung
abchasischer Konfliktzone.
Auf dem Weg
komme ich in Zqaltubo vorbei,
wo die Sowjets
ihre Gesundheit aufpolierten.
Ein Sanatorium aus jener Zeit
ist noch gut in Schuss.
Ein touristisches Highlight:
das Bad von Josef Stalin.
Im Originalzustand.
Hier sass der Diktator einst -
gereinigt und gestärkt.
Ein wenig schaudert es mich.
Eindrücklich, dieser Kurort,
auch wenn die meisten Sanatorien
heute Ruinen sind.
Das war ein Park,
in dem die Leute spazieren gingen.
Wenn wir die Welt kaputt machen,
wird es überall so aussehen.
Nach dem Krieg in Abchasien
anfangs 90er-Jahre
sind viele georgische Vertriebene
in den verlassenen Gebäuden
untergekommen.
30 Jahre später hausen immer noch
Einzelne in den Trümmern,
erzählt man mir.
Aber sichtbar
sind jetzt nur die Bildjägerinnen.
Ich treffe auf Tatyana.
Sie führt Touristen
durch das ex-sowjetische Paradies.
Wo werde ich gezeigt?
Kriege ich Probleme?
Nein, nein, das war ein Witz.
Wenn z.B. Touristen aus Belarus
zu uns kommen,
haben sie Angst,
etwas gegen die Regierung zu sagen.
Wir haben das nicht mehr.
Wenn ich das sehe,
dann ist mir bewusst,
dass wir frei sind.
Auch Tatyana
ist damals als junge Frau
mit drei kleinen Kindern
aus Abchasien geflohen.
Gibt es Unterschiede, wie man lebt -
in Abchasien und hier?
Jetzt?
Vor zehn Tagen schickte man mir
Bilder meines Hauses in Abchasien.
Ich konnte mir das nicht anschauen.
Das ist schrecklich.
Dasselbe wird jetzt
mit Luhansk und Donezk passieren.
Was Russland macht ...
Sie kapieren es nicht.
Es ist schrecklich.
Ich erkannte meine Strasse nicht.
Es gibt keinen Bürgersteig.
* Lautes Bellen *
Das ist mein Haus. Meine Bekannte
geht in meinen Hof rein.
Das war ein schöner Hof.
Sehen Sie diese Ruinen?
Hier links wohnte ich.
Ich habe ihr gesagt:
"Gehe nicht rein,
ich will das nicht sehen."
Gibt es keine Investitionen?
Machen sie nichts?
Sie machen gar nichts.
Ist das vom Krieg zerstört
oder bis jetzt nicht aufgebaut?
Ja, nichts aufgebaut.
Sie leben von den Subventionen,
so eine Art Zauberland.
Man gibt ihnen
immer weniger Almosen.
Sie verstehen nicht, was läuft.
Abchasien, Ossetien, Luhansk
und Donezk - wo wollen sie hin?
Das ist Armut.
Wo kann ich mich sehen?
Nelly wird es Ihnen
per SMS mitteilen.
Können Sie mich
in die Schweiz mitnehmen?
Nur als Ehefrau.
* Lachen *
Es sind nur noch wenige Kilometer
bis zur Grenzlinie.
Man sagt, Abchasiens Klima
sei wie an der Côte d'Azur.
Dazu die Berge des Kaukasus.
Zu gern würde ich hinfahren.
Doch statt Palmen und Zitronen
entdecke ich ein imposantes Bauwerk:
einen riesigen, 15 km langen Tunnel,
der Wasser von Georgien
nach Abchasien führt.
Das Wasser kommt von diesem Stausee,
einem der grössten der Welt.
Der See ist in Georgien,
die Turbinen drüben in Abchasien.
Zur Zusammenarbeit verdammt,
kann man sagen.
Oder auch: ein Glück,
dass es wenigstens in diesem Sektor
einigermassen funktioniert.
Dobry den.
Der Direktor, ein Georgier,
erklärt mir die Situation.
Welche Beziehung haben Sie
mit der politischen Leitung dort?
Eine gute.
Das hier sind die einzigen
Energiequellen in Abchasien.
Sie sind 100 % abhängig
von dieser Station.
Wenn es dort - sagen wir -
zu einem Widerstand kommt
oder zu einem Versuch, die Station
ausser Betrieb zu setzen,
so ist das ganze Wasser
auf unserer Seite.
Also brauchen wir einander.
Wir haben eine gute Beziehung.
Wir hatten bis jetzt keine Konflikte
oder Handlungen, die gemeinsamen
Interessen schaden würden.
Im Energiesektor
gibt es so was nicht.
Wie ist die Stimmung dort?
Darüber möchte ich vor der Kamera
nicht sprechen.
Die wichtigsten Qualitäten
eines Direktors hier
liegen in der Diplomatie.
Immerhin erzählt er mir,
dass die Abchasier
den Strom sehr billig erhalten,
sich aber trotzdem
kaum an den Investitionen beteiligen.
Was genau mit dem Strom
auf der anderen Seite geschehe,
wisse er nicht.
Dann kommt er aber doch noch auf
die russischen Panzer zu sprechen,
die 2008 hier plötzlich auftauchten.
Und er kann sich einen
kleinen Seitenhieb nicht verkneifen:
Sie haben zu wenig Land,
es reicht ihnen nicht.
Wie bitte?
- Es ist nicht genug.
Sie wollen mehr.
Wir unternehmen noch einen letzten
Versuch, nach Abchasien zu gelangen.
Wir haben ja gehofft,
Sie helfen uns, rüberzugehen.
Irgendwie durch den Tunnel.
Nein, das geht nicht.
Ich dachte, wenn das Wasser
durch den Tunnel kommt,
dann gibt es vielleicht auch für uns
eine Möglichkeit.
Nein, nichts.
Es war unsere letzte Chance.
Netterweise führt uns der Kraftwerks-
mitarbeiter dafür zur Konfliktlinie.
Wieder ist Ende Gelände.
Doch dafür fühlt sich das russische
Mobiltelefon von Kameramann Evgeny
plötzlich fast wie zu Hause:
Er hat russisches Netz.
Jetzt bin ich schon nahe der Heimat.
Irgendwo hier ganz in der Nähe
sind meine russischen Grenztruppen.
Freunde?
Bis zu deiner Heimat
ist es noch weit.
Die Heimat ist weit,
die Truppen aber überall.
Deine Truppen sind überall,
aber dort ist meine Heimat.
Nun, ich als Schweizer ...
- Du bist natürlich neutral.
Ich sage ja nicht,
dass ich es gut finde.
Eine komplizierte und intensive Reise
geht an der Küste
des Schwarzen Meeres zu Ende.
Ich verabschiede mich von
der Georgierin Nelly und wünsche ihr,
dass die Europa-Bestrebungen
ihres Landes
die Russen nicht zu einem Szenario
wie in der Ukraine provozieren.
Ein mulmiges Gefühl habe ich
beim Abschied von Kameramann Evgeny.
Er fährt zurück nach Russland.
Wer weiss, wann ich ihn
das nächste Mal treffen kann.
Ich wünsche mir,
dass meine nächste Reise hier
nur noch von der Schönheit der Natur
und den netten Menschen
geprägt sein wird,
und nicht mehr von Hass und Grenzen.
Irgendwann,
in einer leider wohl fernen Zukunft.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2022